elizabeth good morning how can i help
hi thanks so much for talking to me dr
john how are you
i am doing outstanding this morning it's
a blessing to get to just hang out with
everybody how about you
i'm doing well thank you good deal so
how can i help this morning
so um my grandparents have been going
through some really tough times
um and they're just such wonderful
generous people
and i'm just having a really hard time
knowing how to best love and support
them
um in such hard times tell me about hard
times what do hard times mean
so um a little over a month ago my
grandfather was diagnosed with
esophageal cancer
and he's in his 70s so he's um
you know he's really healthy for his age
but
um you know it's just been really
difficult for him and then
a couple weeks ago on their way to
another biopsy
they ended up having to go to the er
because he
um turns out he had an infection in his
hip that went septic
and he was in stage three sepsis and so
they
um he he was he was there for two
and a half weeks and you know they were
just cleaning it out and
trying to get him healthy and you know
they called this last weekend and
said they didn't know if he would make
it and so we went up there to go
just be with my grandmother
fast forward to kind of what's going on
right now he actually made it through
the surgery really well
and he's at home recovering um
until he has to do another surgery to
completely replace the hip
um and praise god they actually had
another biopsy
and um it's completely negative like the
cancer went away while he was there
wow very cool which is which is really
amazing but
um now that they're back home i'm just
kind of trying to figure out
um how to help them they they don't like
to ask or take help they're really
generous themselves but
um you know they don't want to feel like
a burden to others and
i know they've got a lot of medical
bills and they're not really set up
for their future and so i guess i just
was wondering
how i can best support them and then
also kind of how to start
talking with them about hard things like
you know do they have a will or like
what's like the next step i don't feel
like they like to talk about those
things but
you know i i just don't know like what
role i can play
um yeah so here's the deal yeah your
heart is
gold and i can hear it through the phone
and i just want to high five you
from nashville to nevada nope no not
even high five this is
a pre-covered era two-handed front hug
i just want to tell you i love you and
i'm i'm grateful for your heart here
grandparents are precious and they're
beautiful and especially ones that sound
like yours that are generous and giving
and present
and there's nothing more challenging
than watching loved ones
going through pain and hurting both
relationally your poor grandmother's
just watching the man she loves on a
table right and the actual physical pain
that your granddad's going through
and then with that feeling of
helplessness right we can't do anything
about it
yeah um so there's a few things here
that are swirling around in my head and
i'll just lay them out in kind of a
rapid
fire sideways crooked order here okay
the first thing i want you to do do you
have brothers and sisters
yeah okay do they love your grandparents
the same way you do
yeah okay i want you to connect with
them
and whether it is through a zoom
conference
or an email chain or a text chain
my preference would be you all get
together and hang out but depending on
where everybody lives and all that and i
know
everything's the travel's a mess now but
i want you all to
have some fun times remembering the fun
things about grandma and grandad
the crazy things the mean things when
they were super hardcore disciplinarians
back when you were little and how now
they just laugh or whatever
weird little paccadillos your
grandparents have i want you to
spend some time remembering one of the
things that
stinks about when when our loved ones
hurt
is that that becomes our picture of them
and it overshadows
it over weighs like a like a heavy
anxiety blanket
it lays over the just treasure trove of
years and years of beautiful memories
time together laughter
silliness all that stuff right so i want
you to spend some time
proactively with your brothers and
brothers and sisters your siblings
remembering the awesome okay that's for
you that's for your heart
what's going what's going through your
heart and mind right now here's the deal
you've recognized that these pillars in
your family that have held you all up
for years
they're getting old and the one sad
crummy part of this whole existence that
we share is that we all pass away at the
end right
and hopefully they've got 20 more years
that are of awesome fun
silliness my dream is that to be a 90
year old grandparent hosing my grandkids
off in the yard sneaking behind a tree
and just blasting with a water hose that
just sounds like fun to me
my hope is that you'll have that time
but you've got a crack in the armor now
and now you've got a dose of reality
that's just never fun to have to take
the second thing is we often think
people are more
frail emotionally than they really are
occasionally people refuse to talk about
death
occasionally they won't have hard
conversations but often they crave them
they just don't know how to start them
and so one of the greatest gifts you can
give to aging grandparents is
presence is if you can't be in
in contact with them directly is
hand-written letters make it a practice
every week that you write them one funny
story you remember
one time they really surprised you with
their generosity
one like you know deep track a deep cut
from
one of the stories that your mom and dad
told about him about hey one time they
just showed up with the casserole and
some money and helped us out when we
were
newlyweds those kind of old stories
write them down
and send it to them there's something
about it for a grandparent is
understanding that they are leaving a
legacy
they are leaving changed hearts that
they have a family tree that's going to
go on and on
and the more you can reinforce that
either through
you know presence or through something
tangible they can reread and reread and
reread
i remember a conversation i had with my
grandad before he passed
when i called him and just said hey
listen i want you to know you gave me
your last name and i want you to i'm
gonna do the best i can to honor that
you've been a good man my granddad had a
reputation for being really really
really nice he's just the nicest guy
and i told him i'm gonna honor that and
even last night my post on instagram had
something to do with kindness
that's just become part of my dna but i
made sure i let him know this is going
to be something that's going to carry on
when you're gone
and then the thing about the will
there's no way to have that
gently or compassionately or where it's
not weird it's one of those
conversations that you just put out
there
um do you have parents are they involved
in this or is there kind of skipped a
generation where you're connected with
your grandparents pretty closely
yeah my my mom and her sister are
involved but
um there's just some weird family
dynamics there too so i know there's
some
okay we'll save that for another call
um here's i'll just tell you uh a funny
story for my life and it's funny because
i come from a
weird family who's lived and worked
around death a lot
i had a close friend of mine um a really
lovely one of my best friends in the
world and her dad
died suddenly in a tragic car wreck and
he was a police officer
and i was on the phone with her and her
husband he's one of my oldest best
friends in the world when they were
looking for this magic box and most
police officers have a box that has all
of their things in it their will
their passwords their bank accounts
because they know it any day
at any time i may not come home and
they're trained out of the academy
you leave um your home in a state of uh
in a state of neutrality you you let
your family
be able to grieve you and know where all
your stuff is and so police officers
live with this understanding i might die
today
and so i was on the phone with them when
they found the box
and it was a hard crying
hard it was a it was a deep deeply
tragic
but at the same time a beautiful moment
because i remember thinking on the phone
with my friends
what kind of awesome dad this is
incredible man he left it all there just
in case
just in case and just in case happened
so i called my dad
who's a homicide was a homicide
detective for years he was a swat guy
he still was working in a police
department i called him and said
hey dad you need to get a box together
dude of all of this stuff i need to know
where your will is just in case
something happens
and i'll never forget elizabeth he
laughed and he was like
dude it's behind the thing behind the
thing in my closet
and i was like you got a box and he's
like yes john everybody should have a
box
and so it was this it was this moment
i'd built it up i was nervous like cool
let's talk about the wheels
and man it was just like i was asking
him hey can i borrow 50 cents for a coke
and it wasn't a weird thing at all for
him um he told me how the stuff's gonna
work
who's gonna do how and what and it just
ended up being a relatively
high level stress-free conversation and
that was all praise my dad
for for doing that so i tell you that to
tell you i would enter that conversation
directionally
it's a math problem it's not an
emotional problem it's they need to have
a will
and you need to know how you can best
support their legacy their honor
um what they want to have done how you
and your brothers and sisters and
whatever messy dynamics how you can help
navigate that
and ask them directly they may tell you
we're not talking about a will
i don't we're not gonna we're not there
yet stop bringing that nonsense into our
hearts and heads
hopefully they don't they sound like
generous wonderful people and they just
won't but
thank you thank you thank you elizabeth
for that call thanks for reminding me of
how wonderful my granddad was
just spending some time in those
memories just sitting here on the radio
talking to you is a beautiful moment but
at the end of the day you've got to see
a crack in the armor
the strongest pillars of our families
are strong
dads our incredible strong moms
our grandparents who have always been
and it just feels like they're always
going to be
they pass away at the end and it's
heartbreaking
and i hate that it's got to be that way
but it is
there's just some stuff on this side of
the curtain we don't get to figure out
and understand why
but it happens and so the best we can do
is to honor their legacy let them know
that we are honoring them
live lives that honor them and then wow
be direct about the math problem where
the forms where's this
who you want to have the car how do you
want us to divide stuff up those are the
math problems of life that people often
run around and avoid and it takes
somebody like you elizabeth who cares
about her family just to kind of
head right into the middle of that
conversation and i hope that they
respond like my old man did
with directness with a smile with
laughter with
hey i'm a grown-up i've got this figured
out and i'll take care of y'all like i
always have
that's my prayer and hope for you guys
elizabeth